ich befinde mich im madison square
garden dem legendären stadion von new
york city in dem die größten musiker
auftreten und die größten amerikanischen
basketball und eishockey mannschaften
aufeinandertreffen
[Musik]
die arena ist voll
aber heute bin ich nicht hier um bruce
springsteen oder ein nba-spiel zu sehen
es wird eine andere art von spiel
gespielt
[Musik]
die teams treten mit hilfe eines
computers und eines videospiels
gegeneinander an
in den vereinigten staaten nennt man das
sports elektronische sportarten
sie wissen nicht was sie sports ist
keine sorge ich wusste es auch nicht
[Musik]
also beginnen wir mit dem countdown
das spiel fängt gleich an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine generation wuchs mit den ersten
videospielen auf in denen man einfach
nur punkte fressen in vor geistern
fliehen musste
ich bin mit diesen riesigen pixeln groß
geworden
es war ein siegeszug der einfachheit
[Musik]
dann änderte sich alles
videospiele wurden immer komplexer
ausgefeilter und fesselnder
sie sind nicht mehr nur ein zeitvertreib
wie sie es für mich waren
[Musik]
ich schaue mich überwältigt und ich
verstehe nichts ich verstehe das spiel
nicht ich verstehe nicht wann der
richtige zeitpunkt zum jubeln ist
[Applaus]
ich verstehe nicht warum all diese
menschen wegen eines videospiel turniers
hier sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es hängt auch davon ab wer den sammler
hat naja auf papier aber es kommt darauf
an den man hat ja du kannst gewinnen
wenn du den chandler hast ansonsten
endet die leinwände andere deine tour
mein land genau ich bin hier mit eduardo
und francisco sie lieben esports über
alles sie kennen alle regeln des spiels
das ist die geschichte einer realität
die ich völlig ausgeblendet hatte
stilles nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer ist online
schauen wir mal wer online ist lukas
online
bist du noch da ja okay wie lange noch
bis zum spiel sollten es nicht nur fünf
minuten sein wir warten immer was stimmt
aber das geht noch
ihr habt gestern mit evi gespielt
bloody war in der letzten halben stunde
schlecht er musste sich übergeben er
fühlte sich schrecklich also rief evs an
ihr habt gut gespielt eigentlich
hast du gehört dass der typ weg ist nein
er war sauer auf die anderen im team und
anscheinend haben die dann beschlossen
ihn rauszuwerfen hallo hallo hallo
tattoo es beginnt alles in den zimmern
von francisco und eduardo sie haben
zusammen online gespielt und wurden
freunde nur noch eine minute bis wir
anfangen es gibt noch andere spieler und
zusammen bilden sie ein team
sie versuchen sich für ein turnier von
league of legends einen kampf und
strategiespielen zu qualifizieren es ist
das meistgespielte spiel der welt
natürlich hatte ich noch nie davon
gehört lasst uns versuchen das zu
gewinnen ich habe das im griff
nein
ich habe wasser ich entferne die rosa
station
wer in ordnung ich habe die rosa station
entfernt
meine spielerkarriere begann als ich zu
einem der 200 besten spieler europas
wurde
ich denke dass das der richtige weg für
mich ist ich war schon immer gut in
videospielen aber ich habe mich nie
darum bemüht dieses talent zu fördern
wenn sie dich treffen musst du schnell
pushen
ist ein bestimmter polio ich möchte
einfach wissen wie weit ich kommen kann
dort kostenlos
[Musik]
ich möchte sehen ob ich auf die bühne
komme auch der die profis die ich
bewundere jetzt spielen ich möchte sehen
ob ich selbst dorthin gelangen kann
[Musik]
das war ein schlechtes wenn ich wie
kannst du es wagen
im laufe der zeit sogar während der
ersten jahre des spielens bemerkte ich
dass ich heraus stechen wurde ich war
einer der besten gamer in italien ich
war auch der erste der an europäischen
spitzen wettbewerben teilnahm also habe
ich mir gesagt ich bin nicht nur gut ich
kann sogar noch mehr daraus machen
die feature cage es ist schwer zu
glauben wenn man es nicht sieht auch es
ist nicht so schwer wenn es einem
jammert erklärt man würde versuchen eine
verbindung zum internet zur welt
facebook herzustellen man würde
versuchen auf das zurück zu greifen was
andere bereits wissen um es für sie
verständlich zu machen wenn ich nicht
von dieser welt wüsste würde ich auch
sagen dass sie unbegreiflich ist ich
meine das würde ja niemand ahnen können
sie die anna
hilfe
macht den turm blatt ich habe die daten
nicht bekommen nami
vorsichtig verstanden
sie haben uns nicht gehört
[Musik]
mit leute
eduardo und francisco sind in ihren
virtuellen kampf vertieft
aber sie spielen nicht nur sie sprechen
auch miteinander schreiben nachrichten
und checken soziale medien
[Musik]
ihre spielgeschwindigkeit und
reaktionszeit sind unglaublich
es fällt mir schwer dem zu folgen was
sie tun
die komische wie das ist als lebten sie
in einer parallelwelt
[Musik]
aber ich erkenne dass die sich für sie
normal anfühlt am wir ja die winter die
bereitschaft profi gamer zu werden ist
für sie etwas anständiges und normales
die normale
da es nicht seltsam es drum
[Musik]
gute arbeit leute
das war respektlos
gute arbeit
wir haben gut gespielt
ich glaube ich gehe jetzt ins bett in
ordnung wir sprechen uns später okay
tschüss auf wiedersehen
sie haben es geschafft
jetzt werde ich mir den wohlverdienten
schlaf können
das war hart
ich hasse es gegen sie zu spielen
das ist die schlimmste mannschaft gegen
die wir spielen die ist unglaublich
unglaublich
ihr liebstes videospiel league of
legends hat mehr als 100 millionen
abonnenten das zwölffache der schweizer
bevölkerung
die spieler kommen aus 145 verschiedenen
ländern jeden monat spielen sie
durchschnittlich eine milliarde stunden
es ist ein massenphänomen
doch abgesehen von den zahlen
interessiert mich viel mehr warum diese
jungs videospiele so sehr lieben
amstutz oder siena spiele woche ich
organisiere ein kleines turnier
[Musik]
vorsicht vorsichtig leute geht da lang
endlich
[Musik]
als ich klein war vielleicht vier oder
fünf jahre alt entdeckte ich die welt
der videospiele
1900 passiere ich mochte sie und spielte
mehr und mehr
verbindet in der zwischenzeit alles ich
werde es suchen
wie ich liebte es charaktere welten
rollen und alles andere zu wechseln ohne
viel tun zu müssen
ich brauchte nur neues spiel zu
installieren und auf play drücken und
schon war ich in einer völlig anderen
welt
mein vater hat auch immer videospiele
gespielt ich erinnere mich dass er als
sie eine playstation one hatten abends
immer mit uns gespielt hat
ich werde mich immer an resident evil
einer das horrorspiel mit zombies denn
als ich sieben oder acht jahre alt war
habe ich meinem vater bei diesem spiel
zugeschaut manchmal bekam ich angst aber
ich konnte nicht aufhören ihn beim
spielen zuzusehen
[Musik]
es läuft nicht gut für ihn
es ist schwer vorherzusagen wie dieser
runde enden wird das ist ein schöner
movieline er geht zu boden sie haben die
oberhand und haben wieder zurück
gewonnen was sie verloren hatten
2 gegen einen zum nachteil von lemgo der
nur eine b 250 oder eine bombe in der
hand der gegnerischen mannschaft hat
wir könnten eine direkte eliminierung
durchführen nein wir müssen eine direkte
eliminierung durchführen lasst uns das
tun wie sollen wir das anstellen genauso
es hat mich viel zeit gekostet das spiel
zu erlernen mich zu verbessern und meine
gegner zu schlagen
freitagabends war ich bis drei oder vier
uhr morgens aufwachte am
samstagvormittag zwischen 10 und 12 uhr
auf dann war ich wieder wach bis vier
uhr nachts
spielte teils bis zu 14 stunden am tag
das war das maximum das ich hier
geschafft habe
jetzt unter der woche spiele ich etwa 23
stunden am tag
am wochenende der spiele ich etwa sechs
bis acht stunden ich verbringe immer
noch viel zeit damit denn ich habe spaß
daran
warum funktioniert es nicht
zweieinhalb monaten bin ich der liebe
wegen hierher gezogen um mit meiner
freundin zusammen zu leben deshalb bin
ich nach bergamo gekommen das war kein
problem weil ich nur einen computer und
eine gute internetverbindung brauche um
das zu tun was ich mache also war es
kein problem
wurde das interesse an computer und
videospielen in die wiege gelegt denn
meine eltern sind experten und
programmierer und so habe ich schon mit
drei jahren angefangen mit computer und
videospielen herum zu machen
alles selber lenz vor ein paar jahren
schrieb sich jedoch an der universität
ein computer technik zu studieren er
versuchte turniere und ausbildung unter
einen hut zu bringen aber es war einfach
zu viel
das war unmöglich denn sowohl die uni
als auch das spielen nahmen einen
großteil meiner zeit in anspruch spielen
war kein hobby ich hatte turniere und
training es gab eine menge dinge die ich
im auge behalten musste das braucht uns
nicht zu interessieren
irgendwann musste ich mich entscheiden
also verließ ich die uni
wenn ich wollte könnte ich später immer
noch dorthin zurückkehren
ich habe mich dafür entschieden mich
hier auf zu konzentrieren auf dieses
sich schnell ausbreitende phänomen
es wird immer größer und größer also
schmeiße ich mein leben ja nicht einfach
weg ich bin zukunftsorientiert ich
glaube dass gaming in den nächsten
jahren sehr erfolgreich sein wird also
kann ich es ruhig versuchen
ich möchte ihnen ein youtube video
zeigen
renault zeigt mir nachrichten
ausschnitte und ich verstehe was er
meint
ronaldo hatte ein league of legends team
gekauft
das ist ronaldo auch paris st
sie haben auch einen twitter account das
ist der offizielle account von paris st
germain sports sie haben eine menge
follower 35.000 sie haben das team aus
dem nichts aufgebaut
multi millionen dollar verträge
sponsoren
das alles scheint so einfach zu sein
[Musik]
es gibt einige die ins fitnessstudio
gehen aber nicht alle von denen
jeder hat alles hinter sich gelassen und
das aus gutem grund jetzt verdient er
seinen lebensunterhalt in seinem zimmer
von zu hause aus dort verbringt er den
größten teil seiner zeit er arbeitet als
coach für anfänger während er selbst für
turniere trainiert
wir sehen uns später während des live
streams danke dass ihr zeit mit mir
verbracht habt danke dass ihr mir beim
spielen zugesehen habt simple cup
zweimal gewonnen bis später schied leute
und die was soll ich da rein tun was
halt die klappe
nehmen die sachen hier die ich
mitgebracht habe sie zwar auch nein
diese
[Musik]
auf messen sehe ich wie angesagt
videospiele sind
überall wimmelt es von menschen die sich
nach dem neuesten vom neuen umsehen
in riesigen hallen wird für ein geschäft
geworden dass immer profitabler und
attraktiver wird
[Musik]
es ist kein zufall dass viele junge
menschen alles stehen und liegen lassen
um dieses eldorado aufzusuchen ich will
auch 1 vielen dank so wie sie es gemacht
haben youtube stream gamer die erkannt
haben dass sie gut daran sind zu
unterhalten und videos zu machen
dank des internet sammeln sie millionen
von fans und werden zu stars
ich werde neugierig also gehe ich zur
sache
danke sehr danke
ich habe kaum zeit für irgendwas ich
würde gern ins fitnessstudio gehen weil
ich sonst ich werde wenn ich den ganzen
tag nur um sitze das problem ist dass
ich keine zeit dafür habe ich habe nie
so hart gearbeitet bevor ich mit youtube
und twitter angefangen habe
dürfte ich natürlich
danke keine ursache
ich habe alles gemacht wenn jemand
meinen lebenslauf liest wird er es wohl
nicht glauben
fertig
war kellnerin promoterin und barkeeperin
ich habe auch in einem videospiel laden
gearbeitet und war sekretärin in einer
anwaltskanzlei
ich habe viele job gemacht
flüchtig
ich hätte fast gelacht als ich dein
gesicht hinter mir sah
[Musik]
ich bin schon so blass wie ein geist ich
sehe keine sonne weil ich meistens zu
hause bin wenn ich mir also nicht etwas
vater auf die wangen schmiere würden
sich die leute sorgen machen sie fragen
geschont geht's dir gut nein ich bin
kurz vorm sterben
ich bin nicht gut im späten also trage
ich nur etwas rouge auf das was den
eyeliner habe ich heute morgen schon
aufgetragen
so ich bin fertig das ist mein make-up
manchmal kommen mädchen auf mich zu und
fragen sarah kannst du uns zeigen wieder
durch links ich sage ihnen glaubt mir
das wollt ihr nicht sehen
siehst du so sehe ich nicht wie ein
geist aus ich sehe nicht aus wie caspar
ich habe etwas rouge auf meinen lippen
man muss auch sein eigenes herz hören
und herausfinden was man wirklich mit
seinem leben anfangen will in all den
jahren habe ich gemerkt dass ich mich in
jedem job nach einer weile langweilig
blieb jeweils 23 jahre lang anfangs war
ich vielleicht begeistert aber das hielt
nicht lange an irgendwann würde ich
wieder sagen ich will mich verändern ich
habe ständig den job gewechselt das
einzige wofür ich mich immer
interessiert habe sind videospiele
[Musik]
hallo zusammen hier ist coroly
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von game
of thrones jetzt sind wir an der mauer
drei jahre lang habe ich live streams
gemacht und videospiele kommentiert nach
drei jahren als ich sah dass regelmäßig
geld reinkommt sagte ich okay jetzt habe
ich ein festes einkommen ich will
versuchen das hauptberuflich zu machen
[Musik]
besser als ein romantisches date
villa und silva umbringen
ich mache das jetzt seit mehr als einem
jahr hauptberuflich bis jetzt läuft es
gut also mache ich weiter
sarahs beliebtheit wächst von tag zu tag
mittlerweile hat sie fünf millionen
views auf youtube und eine community von
mehr als 60.000 menschen die ihre live
stream verfolgen wir waren zuletzt bei
lilly die die bedrohung durch das team
aqua abwenden musste dass das u-boot
gestohlen hat hatte ich nicht mal eine
taschenlampe nein aber ich habe ein
feuerzeug
ich drehe nicht jeden tag videos aber
fast ich habe einen richtigen zeitplan
montag dienstag von dieser zeit bis zu
dieser zeit es ist wirklich arbeit man
hat feste einsätze und feste freie tage
das kostet ganz schön viel zeit
lade ich das video hoch
hier ist die dame also
kommt schon lasst mich das machen ich
werde später kuscheln
keine sorge jetzt werden wir das finale
pro ok könnt ihr die netten assistenten
sein die so tun als ob
das ist cool
kann das schwert herausgezogen werden
eduardo und französisch großer teil des
italienischen teams forge geworden
francisco ist auf probe und spielt nicht
die ganze zeit nach monatelangem
training und qualifikationen ist es nun
an der zeit für ein wichtiges spiel in
der italienischen liga eduardo ist krank
aber er will trotz grippe spielen sie
haben drinks was sie haben drinks ich
werde dahin gehen bei all den
medikamenten die ich genommen habe würde
mich ein drink ins krankenhaus bringen
ja dich mir geht es gut schön für dich
was willst du tun wir können immer noch
zur bahre wende gewinnen es dauert zu
fuß 5 minuten
willst du ein professioneller gamer
werden
alle gamer wollen an die spitze profi
gamer werden und an großen wettbewerben
teilnehmen nicht nur in italien sondern
auch in europa und in der welt
das ist in ordnung guckte das kabel an
[Musik]
guten abend allerseits guten abend an
alle die heute abend hier sind und guten
abend an alle im stream
hast du die kapitänsbinde ich werde so
machen
wir sind die herausforderer team ford
kommt hoch
diese jungs sind einige der besten
spieler italiens ich will ihr trikot wie
rotes trikot
es ist das klassische amerikanische
trikot
es kann alles passieren
du kannst gewinnen oder verlieren es ist
wie ein würfelspiel du hast eine 50 50
chance wenn du einen guten start hinlegt
und so spielst wie du es normalerweise
tust wird alles gut gehen andernfalls
wenn du anfängst emotional und ängstlich
zu werden könnten dinge schieflaufen
[Applaus]
seid vorsichtig falls sie kommen kämpfen
wir eröffnet den gp macht euch bereit ja
er macht es kaum die so still die
drei bobs wir können es schaffen
[Musik]
ok com sie kämpfen die bot ja ich meine
es war gut nein wir können nicht mehr
lasst uns die raid stehen
komm her lasst sie uns von hinten
angreifen nein zu viele krebs lasst ihr
uns töten
[Musik]
man trainiert monate lang für ein
einziges spiel wenn man verliert waren
all die monate des trainings und sonst
er wird wieder auferstehen es bleibt
nicht mehr viel zeit hier ist die suppe
er stirbt wurde vergiftet von suzuki
selbst sieht ist es egal dass er stirbt
sie und greift weiter an
überdies greift weiter mit seiner axt an
es gelingt ihm nicht jemanden damit zu
treffen aber der in hittfeld ein treffer
nach dem anderen wer will es mit ihm
aufnehmen nein ein blitz hier ist ein
eissturm er schlägt zu schnell
die klappe und komm her nein halt die
klappe und komm her
nautilus ist hinter uns
die mit dem blitz messer
[Musik]
aber wenn du gewinnst kannst du der welt
zeigen wie viel du für diesen moment
trainiert hast und wie gut du bist
[Musik]
mal sehen wen er treffen wird
und er ist unten glückwunsch an das team
fort
applaus
[Applaus]
sollen wir ihnen so nehmen bevor den
hochhebt gärten schritt zurück geben wir
ihn selbst hoch nicht jetzt nein das
können wir nicht feststellen so hin
der sieger ist team fort
gut gemacht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist der stand das ist dass ich habe
es gesehen schau dir das an kennt ihr
das hier
ich hole heute abend mein informatik
diplom von der sp aus locarno ab endlich
ich war schon immer eher vorsichtig ich
spiele gerne zeige allen dass ich der
beste bin und so weiter aber ich möchte
auch gerne etwas richtiges in der hand
haben um meine zukunft damit abzusichern
ich versuche beide seiten von mir im
gleichgewicht zu halten
francisco gatti ja gut gemacht
herzlichen glückwunsch ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]
mein nächstes ziel ist die soaps
universität an der ich informatik
ingenieur werden möchte
dann werde ich weitersehen ich habe vier
jahre zeit darüber nachzudenken
das ist gut
[Gelächter]
diaz wird kunstgeschichte auf die
endnote angerechnet ja
[Musik]
hier ist mein abschlusszeugnis gute
arbeit
ich habe mich gut geschlagen herzlichen
glückwunsch danke ja wirklich danke ich
werde es alvaro zeigen
das ist das ende deines praktikums wir
möchten dass du zu 50 prozent bei uns
arbeitest oder sogar 60 prozent je
nachdem wie viel zeit du für dein
studium an der soap sie brauchst
du hast alle fähigkeiten um
herauszustechen denn du bist sehr gut
das kann ich dir sagen du übertreibst
klein es ist wahr
francisco nimmt die stelle an und
unterschreibt einen vertrag aber
[Musik]
er muss auch an andere dinge denken
es wird die zeit kommen in der ich mich
zwischen videospielen und diesen job
entscheiden muss das hängt vor allem
davon ab welche möglichkeiten sich mir
in zukunft bieten
[Musik]
ich lasse mir alle türen offen
wenn ich den vielversprechenden weg sehe
werde ich den einschlagen
[Musik]
ich habe das intro in ordnung wir sind
bereit
die jungs kaum seht ihr
sie sind schon abschreiben
[Musik]
ich trinke erst
ich habe eine wunderbare community ich
finde es toll dass sie so viel
miteinander zu tun haben sie ist wie
eine kleine familie
na ja nicht so klein wir sind mehr als
60.000
hallo leute
ihr seid schon so viele
[Musik]
okay lass uns mal sehen
bequem so ist es besser lass mich in
ruhe entschuldigung
okay lasst uns beginnen sie sind
miteinander verbunden soll ich dich
einladen ja ok sucht hier aus wenn du
willst
dich was blitz nach gut du wirst
gewinnen lasst uns anfangen
wir haben uns bei einem turnier
kennengelernt ich war dort um anzutreten
ich war mit einer gruppe von leuten
zusammen wir unterhielten uns und ein
mädchen kam auf ihn zu das ist schon
lange her halt die klappe ein hübsches
blondes mädchen kam auf ihn zu und
fragte wann es kann ich deine
telefonnummer haben er wurde so roth
erinnerst du dich er hat sie ihr gegeben
das war ihre freundin ich habe so getan
als wäre ich eines seiner fans so haben
wir angefangen zu chatten sicher du hast
so getan als ob
wir haben viele videos zusammen
aufgenommen wir haben viele spieler
aufgezeichnet wir haben neulich einen
zusammen aufgenommen
nicht wo ich bin
wenn so viel übrig ist bitte ich ihnen
mit mir zu spielen
das ist schwierig manchmal ist es
schwierig ihn zu unterstützen auch wenn
die auswärtsspiele gut organisiert sind
und so ist er oft müde wenn wir
telefonieren ist er erschöpft und seine
stimme ist heiser manchmal hat er mit
fieber und grippe gespielt da mache ich
mir schon ein bisschen sorgen
[Musik]
nichts großes aber ich bin hier und
wartet zu hause auf ihn
ich bin hinter den kulissen hinter der
gut gelaunten fassade
was sagst du das stimmt ich leiden
lassen
ich werde dich töten
mach weiter
wie viele von denen machst du denn
unglaublich wie immer lacht ich aussehe
ich will nicht mehr spielen
ich muss mich konzentrieren
was wir tun
da los
[Musik]
da bist du ja wie geht's wer zum teufel
ist das du verschwindest deine zeit
willst du mich verarschen er hat die
wand durchbrochen ach du scheiße
er hat mich nicht getroffen aber ich bin
tot
großmutter wo ist sie nur
hallo herr franz alles in ordnung ja bei
dir auch gut danke wie ist es gelaufen
du freust dich über das diplom abgesehen
von mathe ich weiß dass ich darin besser
hätte sein können
ach weißt du ich
hab
ich hatte gehofft sie würden etwas mehr
druck machen wie meinst du das in der
schule zum lernen sie haben druck
gemacht
ich weiß dass gut zufrieden stellend ist
aber wenn du mehr punkte bekommen hätte
ist würde ich mich mehr darüber freuen
so sehr wie du dich in andere dinge rein
hängst
du
das ist nicht mein ziel ich muss dich
nicht glücklich machen
danke das ist so nett von dir danke
am anfang war ich wirklich nicht
glücklich darüber weil er zu sehr an
diese spiele vertieft war
ich fand er hätte die möglichkeit haben
müssen auch die welt draußen zu erleben
fußball zu spielen soziale kontakte zu
haben
mir kam es so vor als würde er sich
selbst isolieren
[Musik]
er war in einem wie ich es nenne tunnel
für mich war es ein trommel und es war
ein albtraum weil ich nicht wusste wohin
er führen würde
wohin es ist dunkel es ist dunkel und
das leben ist kein tunnel
[Musik]
ich war wie versteinert vor angst aber
diese angst hatten alle
[Musik]
schau dir diese katze an was willst du
francisco sagen erzählt
ich fing an mich langsam daran zu
gewöhnen je mehr ich mich ihm gegenüber
offen zeigte und ihm zuhörte desto mehr
öffnete er sich auch
ich habe wieder zu meinem enkel gefunden
hat
er hat mir gezeigt dass es da eine ganze
welt zu entdecken gibt
es gibt nur mich dich und die katze
[Musik]
worüber beschwert für dich
cheney war vor sechs jahren beschloss
sich nach mehreren auseinandersetzungen
mit meinen eltern von hier wegzuziehen
also rief ich meine tante an
otto ich fragte sie ob ich eine zeit
lang bei ihr leben könnte
ich habe fast drei jahre gelebt bis zu
meinem vierten lehrjahr dann zog ich zu
meiner großmutter das war näher an der
schule ich konnte eine halbe stunde
später aufstehen
ich bin schon spät ins bett früher
schließlich etwa fünf stunden pro nacht
manchmal sogar weniger
[Musik]
meine mutter lebte in mittelamerika
während mein vater ich glaube er ist
noch in italien aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher
ich verfolge letzter zeit nicht genau wo
er sich aufhält
aber diesen fahrer
was würdest du gerne essen ich weiß es
nicht würdest du mich bitte angucken
was immer du willst du kannst es dir
aussuchen wir haben safran risotto oder
du bist frech oder ich hasse es wenn ihr
mich nicht anschaust wir haben safran
risotto einfache nudeln safran risotto
und safran risotto
sicher
gehst du nicht weg ich gehe jetzt
ist die kamera an darf ich die an den
kurs geben die ist immer an
in ordnung mascus schatz auf wiedersehen
wir sehen uns später ich lasse dich
arbeiten bis später
hinter fantastischen welten und den
schlüssel waren kurz und unmöglichen
strategien lerne ich mehr über diese
jungen männer kennen wie china je mehr
zeit mit ihnen verbringen desto mehr
verstehe ich sie mit all ihren problemen
fehlern tugenden und träumen versuchen
sie ihren weg zu finden
den videospielen scheinen sie einen sinn
zu finden eine antwort auf ihr bedürfnis
sich einen namen zu machen und
erfolgreich zu sein das ist ihre wahl
[Musik]
da
das ist die beste chance die ich in den
letzten vier jahren bekommen habe also
habe ich beschlossen sie zu nutzen und
zu sehen wie es läuft
[Musik]
ich werde es langsam leid alles nur
halbherzig zu machen halb zu arbeiten
und halb zu spielen ich habe beschlossen
mich nur noch auf das spiel zu
konzentrieren und zu sehen wie weit ich
kommen kann
richtig so
francisco ist an einem wendepunkt in
seinem leben angelangt wegen seines jobs
und seine ausbildung hat er nur
gelegentlich gespielt aber jetzt hat er
eine anfrage erhalten
das italienische team volk will ihn als
stammspieler swaswara
francisco akzeptiert und jetzt muss er
ins gaming haus ziehen
weil das du sie alle verloren
august sein
es war keine leichte entscheidung es
gibt eine menge zu bedenken bevor man
seinen job aufgibt
es war gar nicht so einfach aber meine
großmutter meine tante und mein onkel
hat mich unterstützt so dass am ende
alles gut gegangen ist an der turbine
team folgt ist das beste league of
legends team in italien
es verfügt über eine nationalmannschaft
für italienische turniere zu der
francisco und eduardo gehören jonathans
über europäische turnier gibt es eine
weitere mannschaft mit spielern aus
italien südkorea estland und finnland
ein gaming haus ist ein ort an dem die
mitarbeiter und spieler eines teams im
grunde ihr leben teilen
sie teilen sowohl arbeitsräume wie das
büro und die computer als auch private
räume wie die küche die schlafzimmer und
so weiter
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt 30 jahre alt wenn du als
teenager die ganze zeit noch videospiele
gespielt hast warst du ein looser
diese vorstellung existiert heute nicht
mehr dieser welt kann mit der des
traditionellen sports verglichen werden
gut gemacht vom schon gute arbeit gut
gemacht
dani hat ein gutes spiel gemacht
[Musik]
das ist theorie das ist wie sport man
muss viel trainieren
wir haben dann eben nicht mehr viel zeit
für andere dinge
[Musik]
der grund warum ich von zu hause wegging
ist dass sie mich nicht das tun ließen
was ich wollte
[Musik]
ich wollte die schule abbrechen als ich
im dritten jahr der highschool war
es ist nicht so dass bildung nicht
wichtig wäre aber ich habe in der schule
hauptsächlich geschlafen weil ich nachts
durchgespielt habe
[Musik]
ich habe das ganze jahr über nicht
gelernt und dann habe ich versuche alles
in einem monat aufzuholen etwa im april
oder mai
das hat eine zeit lang funktioniert aber
dann bin ich im vierten jahr
durchgefallen
naja das hier hat mich nicht
interessiert
sportlich bringt
[Musik]
dann lockern
liegen
hey leute sushi
sushi wir sind in der unterzahl
er hat sushi gegessen was er hat sushi
gegessen
wer sind wir wer sind wir wie lautet
unser name fort wir sind die besten das
sind wir kommt schon leute wir sind die
besten
[Musik]
allgemein kann das spiel gibt
diesmal sitzt francisco auf der bank
sie schlagen weiter zu aber er wird auch
getroffen
[Musik]
league of legends ist nett es macht spaß
und ist wettbewerbsfähig aber es ist
auch ein trend
hallo leute ich bin kuranyi li hai
[Musik]
es gibt eine menge schöner spiele man
sollte nicht nur eines spielen
deshalb habe ich mich dafür entschieden
mit der unterhaltung zu widmen damit ich
alles spielen kann was mir gefällt
wettbewerber sind schön aber sie sind
nicht leicht die welt der
wettbewerbsspiel ist hart
sie töten den feind koity feld
blumenfeld es sind noch zwei spieler von
next gaming übrig hier ist die suche er
macht weiter sketch das halbe leben ist
sofort weg das spiel ist sehr lang es
dauert länger als vier stunden
es dauert so lange das inzwischen
feierabend ist
das ist eine erinnerung die messe
schließt
die messe schließt und das publikum muss
gehen
die spieler merken dass nicht einmal die
schönen abend auf wiedersehen bist du
auch
was denkst du welche als der beste gegen
dragon hier
tools nicht jeder macht sein eigenes
ding das ist unglaublich
ich werde dich umbringen
wer sind wir
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
er hat fantastisch
hi
ich habe inzwischen vier monate mit
ihnen verbracht die gingen wirklich
schnell vorbei
bevor sie wieder mit dem training
anfangen beschließen eduardo und
francisco sich einen lang gehegten traum
zu erfüllen
wir fahren nach new york zum league of
legends finale
ist dass hier mit dem bildschirm in der
mitte die spieler werden hier sein ich
denke dass sie alle sitze hier entfernen
werden
warst du schon mal im madison square
garden nein ich war noch nie new york
noch nie es ist mein erstes mal
für mich auch
mein telefon ich muss das ladegerät
mitnehmen
sagen wir's ja
wir sehen uns am montag mein schatz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind zurück in new york city bei den
weltmeisterschaften alle wichtigen teams
sind hier
[Applaus]
wenn man es live sieht merkt man dass
alles echt ist dass das wirklich jeder
verfolgt und das spiel mag es ist nicht
nur ein dummes spiel das ist die spots
[Applaus]
wer weiß vielleicht sind in zwei drei
jahren sogar alle europäischen arenen so
voll ich meine das hier ist in nur fünf
jahren erreicht worden
[Applaus]
der gewinner ist die südkoreanische sk
telecom sie sind weltmeister
okay wir beginnen also auf koreanisch
wenn jemand eine frage auf koreanisch
hat hebt die hand ich komme mit dem
mikrofon
wenn jemand so gut ist wird er
normalerweise vergöttert es war wirklich
schön sie zu sehen und zu erkennen dass
sie auch menschen sind
ich bin hier also mit barneys
ein warmes und
zieht vom team force kämen ja
wie gefällt euch new york city
[Musik]
wir sind einer sechsten und müssen an
der achten raus wie lange dauert das
vier minuten
die nächste station ist luca in einer
woche findet dort das finale der
italienischen meisterschaften statt
wir haben nicht viel zeit nur ein paar
tage wir müssen nicht nur gut sein
sondern auch mental gut vorbereitet ich
wäre sehr traurig wenn wir verlieren
[Musik]
im 95 ja das ist gut müssen wir rein
optisch sieht lass uns gehen
wir sind da
es ist eine entweiht kathedrale die ich
für einen tollen ort halte man kann hier
eine menge veranstaltungen organisieren
außerdem ist sie wirklich schön
als ich am freitag an kam schaute ich
mich um und sagte ist das wirklich eine
kathedrale sie nannten sie esl
kathedrale aber ich dachte das wäre nur
ein spitzname
ich hatte unrecht als ich reinkam sagte
ich ist das wirklich eine kathedrale
manchmal rede ich mit leuten die nur 45
jahre älter sind als ich und ich kann
den altersabstand schon spüren sie
fragen mich verbringst du wirklich deine
tage mit video spielen willst du nicht
raus gehen und andere dinge tun ich
denke es ist eine frage der vorliebe
als ich jünger war er vorerst im beruf
wurde war es für mich normal 68 stunden
am stück zu spielen
das war befremdlich weil man wirklich
kein leben hatte
irgendwo muss man eine grenze ziehen
es gibt rehabilitationskliniken ich
glaube nicht dass sie wirklich
funktionieren ich glaube man muss es
selbst wollen so war es auch bei mir an
einem punkt sagte ich mir sarah was
machst du da willst du wirklich den rest
deines lebens 10 12 stunden am tag
zocken vor allem weil es zu dem
zeitpunkt noch nicht einmal mein job war
jetzt könnte ich es verstehen denn das
ist mein job in ordnung ich zähle bis 31
mein ort wird jedes mal wenn wir das
machen ich werde noch taub
das macht süchtig
[Musik]
man muss spüren wann es an der zeit ist
aufzuhören wann es in ordnung ist
draußen ist es gut aber hier ist es zu
heiß ich werde stark schwitzen wie bitte
ich werde ganz schön schwitzen das ist
normal
dieser champion ist nicht nur ein
großartiger sänger sondern er schafft es
sowohl die lanes als auch den dschungel
in eins gegen eins kämpfen zu
beeinflussen klick ist entspannt was
sehr wichtig ist hier ist wieso wladimir
halle schauen sich das finale an der
saal ist voll
draußen gibt es eine jumbo leinwand für
diejenigen die nicht mehr reingekommen
sind
er verteidigt sich er schaffte es ihn zu
treffen er trifft aber ein blitz bringt
ihn zum geschützturm
alle konzentrieren sich auf das spiel
und auf die mannschaften
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ich verstehe das spiel immer noch
nicht aber ich glaube ich verstehe diese
jungs besser
sie haben ein überwältigendes bedürfnis
sich als gruppe zu fühlen und aus ihrem
zimmer herauszukommen zueinanderzufinden
wirklich zusammen zu sein
es ist als ob sie diese nur instinkt
noch spüren könnten trotz aller technik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das bedürfnis nach menschlichem kontakt
und wärme und die kalorien
die diesjährigen italienischen meister
applaus für team fort
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute war ein tag den ich niemals
vergessen werde